nous disons nous sommes naturellement il
n'est pas question d'alliance avec le
front national ça veut pas dire que l'on
est au dessus moi je vois pas pourquoi à
votre avis elle crée ce mouvement dans
le mouvement puisque altics et au 5 de l
air qu est le premier aliment n'est pas
prêt je ne suis pas au dessus c'était un
cas naturellement une progression de
discussions avec les les responsables du
front national laurent wauquiez s'est
exprimé il l'a dit clairement il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté
c'est ce n'est pas un régional de la
faim en revanche je suis votre en
revanche en revanche les électeurs du
front national ne sont pas des sous
citoyens et que et bien sûr que notre
objectif que c'est de dire aux électeurs
du front national comme aux électeurs
déçus qui ne manqueront pas de manuels
macro comme si certains électeurs aussi
de la gauche c'est de leur démontrer que
nous sommes porteurs d'un projet que ce
projet peut rassembler et que
naturellement mais ça l'objectif c'est
de la batterie la vidéo inédite que vous
êtes porteur d'un projet vous nous
expliquer lequel qui peut rassembler
rien n'empêche on à monsieur estrosi par
exemple que vous connaissez bien vous
avez été ministre avec lui estrosi
aujourd'hui puis dit pis que pendre de
du mouvement et par dieu de l air
radicaliser
réunir les élus voilà à partir
radicaliser madame pécresse qui fonde
son petit mouvement mais je façon petit
je ne sais pas il sera peut-être grands
d'ailleurs je tourne les yeux pétillent
la 73e monsieur bertrand
r vous dites que vous êtes vous avez un
parti qui rassemble et qui a un projet
qui crée mais c'est l'objectif c'est
l'objectif mais encore une fois que ceux
qui ont des choses à dire il y avait
quatre candidats par an nous dire s'il y
en a qui avaient des choses à dire
essentiel vraiment essentiel s'il y
avait des divergences profondes mais
surtout que chacun devant on est d'une
grande famille vivante démocratique ce
n'est franchement qu'il n'hésite pas et
la question peut c'est pourquoi ni dont
il pas quelle est la raison il doit bien
d'un avis il doit bien se rendre à
contrôler il doit bien en avoir une
un pourquoi pas si on a des choses à
dire si vraiment il ya telle différence
franchement il y avait une opportunité à
les élever leur dit voilà donc la
réalité c'est que sur le fond il faut au
delà des mots des postures des slogans
et ainsi tweed dire voilà sur tel sujet
il ya il faut que nous en discutions
mais pour l'instant je l'ait pas entendu
moi j'ai pas entendu aucun d'eux aucune
des personnalités pour certaines
d'ailleurs que j'aime beaucoup et que je
respecte
edit ah bah voilà non pas du tout sur
l'immigration fou rire à tout vent j'ai
pas entendu dire pas d'autre nom et au
total désaccord les retraités faut
laisser tomber
bon donc voyez vous encore une fois au
delà des postures des formules des
slogans et peut-être des arrière pensées
eh bien je crois que nous avons les
moyens de rebondir
nous avons un genou à terre et je suis
sûr que avec laurent wauquiez nous
pourrons nous relever